Oh
hey guys it's me patty Harrison I'm
coming to you from San Diego California
for Comic Con 2017 Comic Con oh I'm so
sorry I assaulted that man there are
tens of thousands of people in the
street already we're seeing a lot of
people in amazing cosplay can you take a
guess at what I'm caught playing I'm a
teacher but I'm hard but I mean well
it's you you think I would wear this
dumbass Jerry Bruckheimer directed
by John and Smith looks like Mary Martha
God talk again
hi can you play the gangsters Paradise
by Coolio watch your cent bitch
hey guys as you can see we've made it
into the convention center there's a lot
of people a lot of cool artists there's
also a lot of bad people here too going
to try and avoid those can you take a
guess or what I'm cosplaying oh it's
better we know okay so she's in high
school totally saved all the kids in the
high school right white lady helps
inner-city kids was the name of the
movie
I'm Michelle Pfeiffer from Dangerous
Minds oh my god
[Music]
can you tell what I am you know my
costume is you know my customers I feel
people and I can tell what their
costumes are and no one can tell what my
costume is I was going to lay in the
world
[Music]
oh hi I'm Diane Lane from us love dogs
welcome to Comic Cons 2017 he said you
were cosplaying today I was I actually
dressed as Jim Jeffries today excuse me
I have to say this is the best cosplay
look of the night how I
well I'm dialing from muscle tone having
so much love dogs
do you love dogs you inaudible you
you're liar I thought we were
filming who actually feels any sensible
man you trying to tell me you do
they're all being assholes to me and
thanks you dude there's a lot of
misconceptions about drowning being
painful because you black out huh ok
yeah that makes sense from comic-con
2017 I'm Patti Harrison dressed as Diane
Lane and much loved dogs see you next
year